共同だわー手抜きですすいませんさー今日はもうあの明日の動画のために多分
徹夜で撮影に入るんで
今日は手口ですいつも適当なんだけどね失語いいんですけどが皆さまのおかげで当学者
が100万に入ったということで膨
ず所僕が所属している上めさんからちょっと100万人記念に何かこうとんでもない
ものが届いたので止まず中身知らないですよ本当に中身知らないんで今日はそれを開き
ますいうてねまぁメインチャンネルに上げれくらいだからなぁ相当の本なんで大きさが
ねメインチャンネル投げ合いだからねな小さい個ずつ
海なんてもんじゃないですよ食べバッハ
ねぇ
まいくらなんでも100万人っていうねこんな感じでございます
何なんだの猛禽の再生ほど何かと思ったらそういうわけでもないらしくて事務所の方に
はいつもお世話になっておりますぅの皆さんこれからもよろしくお願いします
世界よね
まずなんなんすか鎌田さんなんだなんですけどは何も聞いてないからそても強いんです
よ
じゃあ開けますよ100万人でしょ
全想像がつかないといった羽化しかななんてその100万人記念で牧之瀬宮園のプレゼ
ンって切ってやりたいってねそれがちょっとや法的に無理で本当に何か分からちょっと
大きいないしましたって言ってたんだよ
ナンディなんじゃないって何
ドッキリかな
いや混ぜか上がそんなことするわけないですよさあ
はは何に者に年ん
おっ
でかまだん
テンパってるん
俺がねを聞いてないよああ
れない何だろう
ha
西南日本だの入ってましたペナン州かマジで頂けます
まだ見てないぞ
ウッウンッ
えっなにみえだとかん
猫は子は高圧変わったら去っていっ
でパッとロギっぽいつぶっ
えっ
ああああああ
ランそれ
うわぁです
まずで事前すかこれちょっと待ってこれはやばいどうすればいい
あっ
なんだでかな具エビの社員さんの皆さんの寄せ書きが非課金さらに茎化銀さんから
コメントに書いてある
あってもねぇさったらもうゴーンがすげー
うずら居づらいで退け分
ブーツに泣いてないですけど
はっはっは
あって
これ護衛の弱いんですよ座ってだってだって
動画とってな相手にバージョンですマジか
ちょっと待ってなぜかんですよで介護 q 1が入っているかと思ったら6世が気に
なってたぞ何か書いてあるして
r
me
うぞ
うわぁエコーユーザーなぁ弱いなぁ
はいというわけで
好きじゃないなんかめざ草大きいのはトロフィーでした
こういうのどこもじゃないかわかりませんで追ったら本当に怒られさあ入ってあげる
ドリーを雷バスターなんか書いてあります
くそだ
だめだ俺に野菜がた彼は本当によくないんででかいと伸びをもらったっていう話でした
僕の返還や何でも一人でショートするんですけど本当に助けられてます梅さんにはもう
神戸ステは
小さい部屋がますます2作なりました本当にありがとうございますというわけでこれ
からも眠生むのサポートの技術ま自分らしく楽しんでいければいいなと思っています
ずっとはて女性が来思い出すとやばいすげー
だめだ明日の動画ちゃんとやらなきゃいけないんだ不敵なお前ら
大事なのはこれを大事だけどね第する方は明日の動画です
ちょっとまず今日はねちょっと気合い入れて頑張るから動画見てる君たちだけじゃなく
てもういろんな人の支えがあってここまで来てます
これからね100万人ユーザーしてえらくね
天狗になって
嘘です今日はね通り普通に行きますじゃあまた明日の動画でお会いしましょう see
you next アイヌ
どこに置けばいいの